I was stalked when I was teaching at
University of Pittsburgh
yep it was really really scary it would
just be everywhere he would know where
when my lights were off no matter what
he would I'd get uh I'd get big missives
that he would write and I'd tear them up
and then I'd just go a few Paces away
and then there'd be a new one that would
be in my purse I'd like how is this
happening it was like really scary and
he followed me when I changed jobs and
went to Brandeis and then he had written
all these open postcards I didn't even
know the people who had hired me I'd met
them once when I had you know you you're
sent and you're supposed to be tested
like do the students like her you teach
for a day right you teach all the
classes and then they decide if they
want to hire you and I got this offer as
an assistant professor I arrived there
the first day in the office and all the
people in the office are looking at each
other like yes well here here's some
cards that have arrived they're sort of
personal